voilà je que j'adore
michel quitterait bien l'album bonne
chanson bon choix
vous arrivez du théâtre la wii comment
ça se passe bien très bien
succès l'an oui sa mamie tu y es sincère
edouard cette mise en scène de bernard
murat qui joue d'ailleurs aussi sur
scène alors le pitch ces deux vieux amis
qui attendent un troisième ami ils
apprennent qu'il est mort et qu'il a
sauté sa fille en ce qui vous concerne
oui voilà et donc c'est un peu problème
que peut poser
l'intervention l'intrusion d'une femme
dans la vie de trois amis qui se
connaissent depuis toujours et quand
cette femme est ma fille c'est encore
plus compliqué oui voilà
mais aucune aucunement
non mais vous ces régions savons si vous
saviez qu'elle se tape un mec de 50
balais ça vous emmerde vrai ça me
poserait un problème probablement oui je
parle ça dépend qui je pensais pas
vraiment le dire ne sent pas prête on
perd à partir de quel âge ça vous
inquiète et leurs 20 ans pas de problème
je sais pas je crois que l'importance de
l'événement elle soit elle soit heureuse
mais un problème se pose non
sérieusement les problèmes se poseront
un jour ou l'autre bon et ça finira
probablement mal les attirée par les
hommes mûrs tu veux voir pose la
question alors vous toute façon vous
risquez rien parce qu'il n'est pas
question michel de tromper votre femme
béatrice
d'abord parce que c'est la patronne a
quand même à la haye lundi par thai binh
à l'armée c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
elle vous tient la route irish micky
produits wifi voilà c'est ça qui a
produit l'album goodbye to hell produite
ou la lésion est le cas la caisse les
enfants voilà les enfants rient donc pas
question de la tromper d'abord parce que
c'est la patronne ou alors faut pas se
faire voler sa voix à la chaussée et
chose plus peux dire c'est que vous avez
été très marquée par la séparation de
vos parents vos oui bon passait pas mais
si vous n'avez pas envie de [ __ ] le
bordel vous avez vu ce que c'était
oui bien sûr
et non je ne suis pas je suis pas mark
buehrle mon père l'a tué non mais celle
là c'est vrai que j'ai des périodes de
la vie quand on est adolescent des
parents se séparent c'est assez
difficile à vivre
bon et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je peux
pas imaginer qu'une situation comme ça
se reproduise ne serait-ce qu
effectivement pour pour leur équilibre
bon bah c'est voilà ça va pas plus loin
que ça donc je fais ce qu'il faut pour
que ça ne se passe pas oui non mais en
87 dans sexy folies quand vous avoué
avoir trompé votre femme dans sexy money
oui en 87 dans sexy folies quand vous
avoué avoir trompé votre femme
c'était pas vrai alors non c'est pour
faire une émission de télévision à
l'accord de la vallée dakar la promotion
oui mais c'était pas vrai mais nous ne
revenons pas extraordinaire oui non
parce que je me disais quand même c'est
pas possible on les aidera pas comme ça
en trente ans de métier
quand vous dites la fidélité ça se passe
dans la tête à l'époque si je disais ça
n'est pas must est beaucoup plus jeunes
aux six mois là mais c'était alors les
choses évoluent d'un calme un peu ouais
ouais normal on arrive à un âge où on
réfléchit
attention c'est que s'ils n'étaient pas
à dire la même chose on l'a fait sortir
pour voir justement comparé êtes sages
alors très sale donc c'est bien
je félicite ces gentils en tous les cas
il ya une chose c'est que désormais vous
semblez très bien accepté par le milieu
du théâtre désormais désormais parce que
c'est vrai que c'est difficile d'avoir
la carte vous savez bien qu'à un moment
c'est un peu compliqué pour vous les
verrez l'époque du sketch là ce ne sont
pas mes mes narines ce sont mes ray-ban
ça vous à oui biensur plombé cette
histoire bon c'est vrai qu'à un moment
voilà vous aviez du mal à être reconnu
être respecté et aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que je les trouvais quand
même un clan qui vous a accueilli vous
êtes bien vous êtes à l'aise
oui je suis j'ai toujours été de toute
façon prêts très heureux de ce que je
faisais au moment où je le faisais
jamais de regret à lille 2-2 mais c'est
jamais bien accepter qu'on arrive d'une
famille et qu'on rentre dans une autre
ça c'est toujours mais jordi savall très
bien ça va dire que je ferais comment
votre père en ce moment la famille une
tête en 10 ans s'est détendu il est
voilà ouais elle ressemble à ça mais
sinon tu aimes bien trompeur tous les
bateaux tous les oiseaux toujours avec
les choses qui fait merveille
petit fils ma rue
tu n'as jamais vu
les batwa
ils vont tout
soleil
il veut préparer
beaucoup de toi la gare card sado-maso
vous devez vous arracher les poils
ah bon des fois les ce truc pas les
poils un ouais tu connais l'histoire du
château
non il peut s'en sortir avec une
histoire mais c'est l'histoire le maso
qui dit ça nos fais moi mal lotis dit
non merci
un poil
bien michel je crois que vous vouliez
dire un mot des enfants de beslan donc
c'est ses mille enfants qui ont été
otage pendant trois jours ensuite il ya
eu l'assaut de l'armée russe 360 morts
dont 189 enfin voilà alors l'unicef s'en
occuper vous vous aider l'unicef
voilà c'est à dire qu'on a fait un un
petit spot qui va être diffusé sur
toutes les chaînes où on on parle de ses
enfants c'est évidemment dès qu'il
s'agit d'enfants on s'investit sans s'en
sont retenus complètement d'une manière
complètement libre et surtout parce
qu'aussi les enfants sont dans un
univers que celui de l'école et l'école
c'est en principe le lieu elle
démocratie tu as he is est empreint de
la paix dans un pays comme la russie ou
ayant en particulier en ossétie du nord
qui se veut un pays démocratique
tout s'est passé exactement l inverse de
ce qu'ils avaient l'intention de montrer
au monde donc ça a été quelque chose
d'horrible et d'inde insupportable et
donc j'espère que ce message qui va être
diffusé sur toutes les chaînes pas
toucher les gens parce que c'est on doit
pas oublier les enfants me de baisse
l'année ils sont une initiative et ils
ont été otage pendant plusieurs jours et
là je ne voudrais pas qu'il soit otage
de une forme d'indifférence qu'on a ici
chez nous donc il faut vraiment quand on
sache